government should not require any texan
to show proof of vaccination and reveal
private health information just to go
about their daily lives bottom line is
we're going to continue to implement the
law which the president of the united
states has the ability the authority the
legal authority to do
texas governor greg abbott and white
house press secretary jan saki sparring
over the legality of the binding
administration's vaccine mandates as the
fight between the white house and
republican governors heats up
joining us now for reaction is urban
reform president and member of the texas
advisory committee of the u.s commission
on civil rights charles blaine charles
thank you so much for being with us
thanks for for having me jackie so uh
walk us through charles what's what's
your take on where things stand right
now
well listen i i applaud the governor for
doing what he did i think one of the big
things that has been a part of the
conversation about vaccine and vaccine
mandates is that one of the big groups
that have been reluctant to get them
they look like me so we're talking about
black and hispanic folks largely folks
who are wage workers who are working
public-facing jobs so they're going to
really feel the crunch of a vaccine
mandate and so with the governor
stepping in it's ensuring that they
don't have to make the decision of their
livelihood and continuing to put food on
the table
versus what they feel is right for their
personal health so i applaud the
decision and i think he needs to hold
steady on it
in your view what would be the better
role of the government then to try to
encourage
vaccine hesitant populations to get
vaccinated
well i think you know locally here in
harris county in houston we've seen our
local officials getting out there and
going to community events holding
vaccination events really showing that
they are getting it themselves and that
it's a safe and effective way of
combating this virus but the mandate
doesn't seem to be the answer people
especially the people that we mentioned
black and hispanic folks are already
hesitant of government and they have a
deep mistrust of government so mandating
something from government is not going
to going to fly with them and so i
really think that just getting out there
and communicating continuing to
communicate the message of the need for
vaccines and the need to
ensure that the population is safe is
going to be what the answer is i don't
think mandates are it so in your view
then the mandate does the opposite it
makes them more hesitant
oh without a doubt i mean it makes them
more hesitant and i think it makes them
question the motives of government
simply because what now you're saying is
that they have to make that decision
between their livelihood and what they
choose for their personal health so i
definitely think it does the complete
opposite and there was there was
conversation shortly after he announced
his mandate that
uh the black voters who supported him
previously were a little more um
questioning what he was doing and they
were a little more reluctant to support
him going forward and i think that's
going to be a long-standing thing if he
continues to kind of shove this down a
population's throat that has a deep
mistrust of government well the biden
administration though also has been
careful to try to find ways where they
do have legal ground to do that in terms
of
you know encouraging businesses to make
these mandates where they cannot
reach over in their federal capacity
do you think that that makes a
difference if it's coming from you know
your employer at the urging of the
government versus uh you know some sort
of a mandate that's enacted by the
department of labor for instance for
certain employers with uh more than 100
workers do you think that that makes a
difference if it's coming from the white
house versus the person you work for
i don't think it makes a difference for
the average person because at the end of
the day they then still have to make
that decision between what they're
choosing for their personal health care
and whether or not they're going to
continue to put food on the table and
bring a paycheck home every two weeks or
every end of the month so i don't really
think it makes much of a difference and
i think people recognize that the the
force of this is still coming from
government that whether or not their
employers choose to adhere to a mandate
or violate it themselves and put
themselves at risk that force that that
strong arm of the federal government is
still coming down and so you know that's
why again i applaud governor everett for
what he did and i'm applauding our texas
legislature for considering legislation
to codify what his executive order says
all right charles blaine thank you so
much enjoy the conversation hope to talk
to you again soon
thank you thanks